what do you think happens in a  relationship when the woman out earns  what the man earns it's gonna end in  divorce more than likely so there's a  study conducted by american  psychologists and they found that if a  woman out earned her husband it was 50  likely that the marriage would end in  divorce so what's the solution there i  don't think there is a solution i think  that people should probably lower their  expectations in terms of understanding  that okay well this person is the  breadwinner it's how the situation is it  probably comes down to being able to met  out responsibilities on the part of both  sexes and sometimes the man stays home  and takes care of children and sometimes  the woman goes out there and earns the  money and so it probably is contingent  on both partners understanding that this  is the role that is played okay that  makes sense